Salut, moi c'est Guillaume Hachez. Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec. Hello there. Ça fait à peu près deux mois qu'on ne s'est pas parlé.
Je suis désolé. Pour ma défense, j'ai déménagé au début du mois de décembre. Bonne année au passage, mieux vaut tard que jamais.
Et puis, après mon déménagement, j'ai dû attendre hyper longtemps avant que ma connexion Internet soit activée. Puis après ça, j'ai dû rattraper des semaines de boulot.
Bref, j'arrête de raconter ma vie. La bonne nouvelle, c'est que je suis très content d'avoir enfin pu réaliser un épisode qui me faisait envie depuis une éternité.
Pendant très longtemps, je me suis posé la question de faire un épisode sur le narcissisme. On a tous croisé,
la route un jour de ces personnes hyper imbues d'elles-mêmes, qui ont un besoin constant d'impressionner, qui veulent être perçues comme exceptionnelles, spéciales,
parfois jusqu'au point de déformer la réalité ou de péter un câble quand on les critique.
Je me souviens, il y a presque trois ans, quand j'annonçais tout excité à mon associé que j'allais interviewer et rencontrer Alexander De Croo, sa réaction, c'était littéralement : « Mais, mais, mais ça devrait être moi.
» Et puis, plus tard, quand j'ai publié mon article sur le manque de femmes dans le secteur informatique en Belgique,
y a une Américaine qui, à un moment donné, m'avait effectivement donné deux, trois pistes, deux, trois idées que je pouvais approfondir pour travailler mon sujet et qui,
quand l'article a été publié, m'a engueulé comme du pu parce que je n'avais pas écrit trois paragraphes pour expliquer qu'elle était formidable et que la Belgique lui devait énormément.
C'était très bizarre. Bref, je me disais qu'il y avait un sujet à faire là-dessus. Mais le problème, c'est qu'en faisant les recherches, j'ai vite été confronté au fait que le narcissisme, c'est un peu une tarte à la crème.
C'est un mot qui peut prendre plein de sens différents selon la personne à qui vous allez poser la question. Et surtout, c'est un terme qui, à la base, vient de la psychanalyse.
Du coup, quand je faisais les recherches, je tombais sur énormément de conneries freudiennes. Et ça, ça m'a bien refroidi.
Et puis j'ai fini par tomber sur un autre mot beaucoup plus intéressant. Aujourd'hui, on va parler d'individualisme avec le professeur Vincent de Coorebyter.
Alors, juste un petit détail, on a fait l'interview dans mon nouvel appartement et malheureusement, il y a pas mal d'écho dans mon salon.
Il va falloir que je règle ça. Du coup, j'ai fait mon possible pour réparer ça au montage. C'est pas parfait, mais voilà, je pense que ça reste écoutable.
Toutes mes excuses. Bonne écoute. J'ai aujourd'hui le plaisir de recevoir Vincent de Coorebyter. Vincent de Coorebyter, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Vincent de Coorebyter, vous êtes professeur de philosophie sociale,
politique et contemporaine à l'Université Libre de Bruxelles et vous vous spécialisez, entre autres choses, en tout cas, c'est le sujet dont nous allons parler aujourd'hui,
sur les questions liées à l'individualisme.
Alors, je suis effectivement professeur de philosophie sociale et politique contemporaine à l'ULB. Je ne suis pas un spécialiste de l'individualisme.
Il se trouve que j'y donne depuis huit ans, quasiment sans interruption, un cours en première année sur la question de l'individualisme qui est un peu une sorte de,
de violon d'Ingres, de sociologie en amateur, mais qui m'intéresse parce qu'évidemment, derrière la question de l'individualisme contemporain, pour un public de jeunes étudiants, il y a une question philosophique qui est de se connaître soi-même.
Qu'est-ce que ça signifie de vivre dans une société d'individus individualistes qui est une évidence pour les jeunes et qui est une innovation historique, qui est très située aussi dans l'espace, qui est d'abord un phénomène
de l'Europe de l'Ouest, de l'Amérique du Nord, même s'il se diffuse sous des formes variables au-delà.
Et donc, pour moi, c'est aussi renouer avec une interrogation philosophique, mais sous un angle plus sociologique.
Qu'est-ce qui vous amène, vous, personnellement, vers ce sujet-là ?
Alors, de manière globale, il y a un certain désir d'essayer de comprendre le monde dans lequel je vis. Ça, c'est le, je dirais, le travail de l'intellectuel-
Oui
...en utilisant le terme de manière modeste.
Dans ce cadre-là, moi, j'ai été marqué très tôt par une vision, disons, marxisante, qui donne beaucoup d'importance à l'impact des structures économiques et sociales sur l'évolution des mentalités, des valeurs, des comportements
et donc une vision matérialiste.
Et il se trouve que il y a eu deux coïncidences qui ont joué. J'ai découvert en 2006 dans Le Nouvel Observateur un article très élogieux
d'un livre d'un sociologue français qui m'était totalement inconnu, Paul Yonnet, et qui, d'après Le Nouvel Observateur, avait défendu une thèse
atypique selon laquelle l'individualisme n'avait rien à voir avec l'évolution du capitalisme ou des structures socioéconomiques, mais était le résultat d'une mutation démographique.
Ce qui m'a interpellé, on disait tellement de bien du livre que je l'ai acheté et je l'ai lu avec saisissement et avec beaucoup d'intérêt.
Et il se trouve qu'à peu près à la même époque, j'ai trouvé chez un bouquiniste un livre dont je savais qu'il avait une grande réputation, qui est le livre de David Riesman, La Foule solitaire.
Yonnet, c'est un livre de 2006, Riesman, c'est 1950. Et je les ai lus à peu près à la même époque et les deux ensemble fournissaient un tableau qui n'est pas identique, mais qui, au total, était assez fascinant de,
de la société contemporaine sous l'angle de l'individualisme.
Et c'est une question qui est restée un peu vivante dans mon esprit. Et puis j'ai décidé d'en faire un sujet de cours parce que ça me paraissait, comme je le disais, interpellant, pour de jeunes étudiants.
Un sujet de cours et puis un livre, puisque en 2015, vous avez publié
à l'Académie Royale de Belgique, un livre nommé Deux figures de l'individualisme, où vous parlez justement de David Riesman et de Paul Yonnet, de leurs travaux sur l'individualisme.
On va explorer ces deux auteurs dans un instant, mais avant ça, pour celles et ceux qui nous écoutent, si je devais vous demander ce que c'est l'individualisme.
Quelle définition est-ce que vous en donneriez sans en faire un cours d'un quadrimestre ?
Bien entendu, oui. Mais c'est là que la question devient passionnante, c'est qu'il n'y a pas forcément une réponse.
La manière dont les individus se vivent aujourd'hui n'est pas celle qui prévalait, pour faire simple, dans la seconde moitié du XIXe siècle.
Aujourd'hui, l'individualisme, c'est essentiellement un mouvement par lequel les individus s'affichent autonomes, créateurs de leurs propres règles.
Étymologiquement, autonome, c'est autonomos, je crée ma norme moi-même. On est maître de ses choix de vie, on est maître de ses valeurs, on est maître de ses comportements.
Ça veut dire qu'on se détache potentiellement de ce qu'on nous a appris, qu'on a un rapport très distancié à l'égard de l'autorité, qu'on n'accepte pas facilement l'autorité d'un maître ou une autorité politique.
Il y a sûrement un lien entre l'individualisme et ce qu'on appelle la crise de la démocratie ou la crise de la représentation politique.
Et cet individu contemporain est aussi très assuré de sa singularité. C'est une évidence que chacun
est différent d'un autre,
possède, alors, il y a tout un vocabulaire, une essence, un moi profond, une personnalité, doit s'engager sur la voie d'un développement personnel pour exploiter au mieux ses propres ressources, ce qui le fait différent des autres.
Mais en tout cas, il y a cette certitude-là.
Ce que Riesman a étudié, entre autres choses, mais de la manière la plus convaincante dans La Foule solitaire dont on parlait il y a un instant,
c'est une autre forme d'individualisme qui, pour lui, démarre à la Renaissance et connaît son apogée dans la seconde moitié du XIXe, début du XXe siècle.
C'est un phénomène assez typiquement bourgeois.
C'est une manière de préparer les individus à tirer le meilleur profit de leurs ressources dans un monde qui change et qui ouvre sans cesse de nouvelles opportunités, notamment au plan social et professionnel.
On n'est plus dans une société relativement fermée, relativement immobile, où les individus ont une fonction assignée par leur statut, par leur naissance.
Vous êtes fils de paysan, vous terminerez paysan. Vous êtes fils d'artisan, vous terminerez artisan.
Les trois ordres médiévaux.
Voilà. On n'est plus dans une société d'ordre qui enferme les individus dans un rôle.
On entre dans une société bourgeoise qui exploite les grands espaces, le commerce international, la manufacture, l'industrie, qui offre une multitude de métiers, de perspectives de progression sociale.
De sorte que, pour Riesman, se met en place un nouveau type d'éducation, beaucoup plus long et beaucoup plus rigide, de manière à préparer les enfants à tirer parti
des opportunités futures et de réussir leur vie au maximum, avec un accompagnement très strict de la part des parents,
de la part de l'école, de la part des instances religieuses, de la part des précepteurs, des maîtres qui viennent enseigner à domicile,
de manière à ce que ces enfants apprennent très tôt un maximum de connaissances, de règles, de codes de comportement assez austères.
C'est très rigide, c'est assez étouffant, c'est extrêmement peu attrayant pour nos mentalités contemporaines, mais ça devait doter l'individu d'un individualisme au sens d'une indépendance, une capacité à s'autodéterminer.
Riesman parlait d'intro-détermination. Je trouve en moi-même ma détermination, ma motivation à agir et j'agis de manière déterminée, c'est-à-dire que je suis lancé une fois pour toutes dans la conquête d'un idéal
social, professionnel, d'enrichissement ou bien de réussite dans le domaine de la science, ou bien je vais devenir un haut responsable politique.
D'une manière ou d'une autre, une formule de Gide résume très bien ça : il faut suivre sa pente, pourvu que ce soit en montant.
Et donc là, c'est un individu qui est appelé pas à cultiver sa différence, on n'est pas dans le schéma contemporain que j'ai rappelé, mais à se montrer indépendant des autres pour s'accomplir, mais en conformité avec un idéal social du grand homme.
C'est l'époque où les bibliothèques sont remplies de livres édifiants nous racontant les destins des grands capitaines d'industrie, des grands savants, des chefs d'État, des figures éminentes de l'Église.
Où on apprend aux enfants, plutôt de bonne famille, qu'ils vont donc devoir s'élever au sommet de l'humanité. Et donc on leur assigne une mission qui n'est pas définie dans le détail, mais qui est quand même une mission ascensionnelle.
Alors qu'aujourd'hui, l'individualisme contemporain dit plutôt aux individus : sois toi-même, fais ce que tu veux. Il y a un petit exemple.
Il y a eu, il y a deux mois,
trois mois, dans le réseau de la STIB à Bruxelles, dans les transports en commun, une campagne d'affichage tout à fait caractéristique de l'individualisme contemporain, où on voyait des jeunes, une jeune femme en foulard, un jeune métis,
interpellés avec comme accroche : « Rêveuse, rêveur,
tu as des rêves, tu n'as pas d'emploi, tu n'as pas de formation, tu as mille doutes.
C'est parfait. C'est toi que nous voulons.
» C'est-à-dire que l'on dit à des jeunes en fait sans emploi
: nous allons te mettre à l'emploi en te prenant comme tu es, avec toutes tes failles, avec tous tes doutes, avec ce que il y a cinquante ans, on aurait considéré comme des carences inquiétantes pour un employeur.
On te prend tel que tu es. Ça, c'est un individualisme contemporain. Dans l'individualisme intro-déterminé que développe Riesman, c'est plutôt : on va te faire devenir plus que ce que tu es au départ.
Oui, oui. Donc, il y a une injonction à la réussite, au succès, injonction à réaliser ses propres rêves, mais ses propres rêves sont-
Sont très normés-
Voilà
...dans l'ancien individualisme.
On les hérite de notre environnement, de notre culture, de nos parents. On va découvrir tout à l'heure ce que ça devient par après, donc l'individualisme plutôt contemporain, voilà, que décrit peut-être Paul Yonnet.
Mais on parlait il y a un instant du fait que auparavant
À l'époque médiévale, on fonctionnait voilà de façon extrêmement normée, encore plus normée avec ces trois ordres, où on était, soit on priait, soit on combattait, soit on travaillait, pour dire ça comme ça.
Et la question que j'avais envie de vous poser, c'est : qu'est-ce qui amène la transition de ce monde-là, ce monde très ordonné, ces trois ordres, vers un système plus individualiste tel que le décrit Riesman ?
La thèse de Riesman, qui me paraît globalement assez juste, mais qui est évidemment partielle, c'est que ça démarre à la Renaissance par ce phénomène que j'évoquais rapidement.
La Renaissance, ça veut dire on commence à remettre en cause certaines structures intellectuelles typiquement médiévales en revenant à l'Antiquité.
On fait renaître les auteurs de l'Antiquité. Or, l'Antiquité avait connu une certaine forme d'individualisme dans la, à l'époque romaine, notamment l'individu et en particulier le père de famille, le pater familias, avait des droits.
Le droit romain est un droit assez individualiste. On redécouvre des auteurs anciens, mais on découvre aussi des continents ou des contrées nouvelles.
Il y a beaucoup plus d'échanges intellectuels qui vont bien au-delà des espaces nationaux. On entre dans la période des grandes découvertes, des voyages au long cours, des échanges économiques, la soie,
les épices, les métaux précieux.
La place de l'aristocratie, progressivement, qui, elle, reste souvent campée sur des schémas très rigides, se relativise progressivement parce que ce sont les marchands,
puis les premiers manufacturiers, puis le monde de l'industrie-
Mh
...qui commence à dominer. Et l'élément commun de tous ces phénomènes, c'est l'ouverture de possibilités. C'est un champ tout à fait nouveau,
de capacités de carrière, de capacités d'enrichissement, des,
des opportunités pour tenter des aventures qui jusque-là étaient impossibles parce qu'elles demandaient des progrès techniques dans les techniques de navigation,
puis plus tard, des améliorations des techniques agricoles et puis aussi, bien entendu,
tout ce qui avait amené le développement de la, de l'industrie.
Donc l'explication majeure pour Riesman est d'ordre économique et social.
Alors, on peut en discuter. Il faudrait aussi intégrer dans le tableau une certaine modification des mentalités, mais dont on peut facilement montrer qu'elle est liée à ce changement économique.
Dès le XIIe, XIIIe siècle, on voit des formes d'individualité s'affirmer, donc vers la fin du Moyen Âge, en particulier, pas seulement, mais dans le milieu des marchands.
Parce qu'être marchand, c'est se préoccuper de soi et de sa réussite
en dehors des codes dominants, parce que les codes dominants sont encore
régis par l'Église qui condamne la recherche de l'enrichissement,
qui condamne le prêt à intérêt, ce qu'on appelle l'usure, qui voit d'un mauvais œil la préoccupation de son bonheur ici-bas, alors que l'essentiel, c'est se préoccuper de son salut dans l'au-delà.
Mais on voit dès le XIIe, XIIIe siècle un début de basculement des mentalités et un début de valorisation de cette activité très profane qu'est le travail du marchand, cette préoccupation d'enrichissement.
Donc, on peut plaider que l'essentiel de la transformation est dû à des modifications dans les manières de vivre au sens professionnel, économique, social du terme.
Oui, il y a une compétitivité intrinsèque. Voilà, c'est la théorie du libéralisme. C'est finalement, on va chercher à se distinguer, à voilà, à développer-
Oui
...ses particularités.
Et on finit par développer une nouvelle anthropologie-
Mh
...radicalement différente de celle qui dominait, par exemple, au XIe siècle et qui va considérer que l'être humain, c'est un individu, un individu qui pense.
C'est Descartes, un individu qui sent dans le courant empiriste, un individu qui se préoccupe de ses intérêts économiques, financiers.
C'est ce qu'on a appelé après coup l'homo economicus, l'homme défini comme une sorte de,
d'égocentrique qui cherche exclusivement la réalisation de son bonheur, qui entre du coup effectivement en rapport potentiellement de conflit avec les autres, mais aussi en rapport de commerce.
Et à l'époque, le terme de commerce, c'était à la fois l'échange commercial, mais aussi l'échange social. C'est aussi une nouvelle sociabilité où on peut s'adresser à des personnes indépendamment des castes,
parce qu'on commence à se reconnaître comme être humain, quel que soit, à certains égards, le statut social, même s'il ne faut pas rêver, ce n'est pas une ouverture complète,
mais en tout cas, définition d'un être humain qui n'est plus
d'abord considéré dans son rapport à Dieu et dans sa fonction sociale acquise à la naissance, mais plutôt comme une sorte de petite cellule fermée sur elle-même et préoccupée de ses intérêts.
Et donc vous disiez que
selon David Riesman, la culmination de tout cela, c'était fin du XIXe, début du XXe, ce qui correspond donc à,
la révolution industrielle, et donc voilà, la démultiplication des possibles et donc une plus grande place à l'individualité.
Si on transitionne tout doucement vers le deuxième auteur de votre, voilà, que vous explorez dans votre livre, Paul Yonnet.
D'abord, qu'est-ce qui caractérise sa vision de l'individualisme et qu'est-ce qui amène aussi, de nouveau, la transition ?
Quelle explication pour ce changement de modèle d'individualisme ?
Alors une caractéristique forte de Yonnet, c'est que c'est un sociologue un petit peu marginal, qui n'a pas du tout fait sa carrière à l'université, mais qui a fait sa carrière dans l'administration des allocations familiales en France.
Il était très méfiant à l'égard de la sociologie qui était à l'époque dominante quand il a fait ses études. Sociologie assez marxisante, dominée notamment par la figure de Bourdieu.
Sociologie qui nous explique à quel point l'individu est plus ou moins
maîtrisé, normé, conduit à adopter des conduites conformes à ce que la société attend de lui en fonction de rapports sociaux inégalitaires, problématiques des classes sociales et de l'obéissance à la hiérarchie sociale.
Yonnet a toujours été assez méfiant à cet égard, a exploré
une sociologie des modes de vie, des nouvelles pratiques, grand spécialiste du rock, des pratiques culturelles des jeunes, a écrit des chapitres entiers sur des phénomènes inédits comme l'explosion des animaux domestiques.
Pourquoi y a-t-il autant de chiens et de chats depuis quelques dizaines d'années dans les, la plupart des maisons ? Quelque chose qui serait apparu comme tout à fait étonnant quelques siècles auparavant.
Et progressivement, il a tissé une explication qu'il développe dans ce livre paru en 2006, Le recul de la mort, qui est assez radicalement alternative parce que elle place à l'origine de l'individualisme une double révolution démographique.
Pas économique, pas sociale, mais démographique.
Il y a toute une foule de références historiques, de statistiques qui sont rassemblées par Yonnet pour nous rappeler d'une part que l'humanité a toujours essayé de faire reculer la mort,
de faire reculer l'âge de la mort et de faire diminuer la mortalité, notamment la mortalité des femmes en couches et la mortalité des enfants, des très jeunes enfants ou à la naissance même,
et que par ailleurs, l'humanité a toujours essayé de réguler les naissances.
Bien consciente qu'il était important d'avoir plusieurs enfants pour assurer la prise en charge des aînés, mais qu'avoir trop d'enfants, c'était se mettre face à des défis insurmontables.
Il faut les nourrir, il faut leur assurer un avenir. Et il étudie tout cela de manière assez serrée pour montrer que ce double combat de recul de la mort et de régulation des naissances,
est gagné dans l'après Seconde Guerre mondiale.
Et c'est à ce moment-là, pour Yonnet, que du coup, sur la base de cette révolution démographique, se met en place un nouveau type d'individu.
Donc une révolution technique de la médecine.
Donc c'est essentiellement du côté de la médecine que ça s'est joué.
Voilà, oui.
Mais sur la base d'une volonté des peuples, des individus. Ça n'est pas une injonction sociale qui nous pousse à vouloir faire reculer la mort et à contrôler les naissances.
Au contraire, pour Yonnet, c'est spontanément que dans toutes les sociétés, tout au long de l'histoire, on a tenté de réussir cette double entreprise.
Et donc, pour lui, les acteurs sociaux sont beaucoup plus libres que ce qu'en dit la sociologie de la domination qui nous les montre manipulés en quelque sorte par les grandes puissances sociales.
Et est-ce que ce n'est pas aussi lié donc, puisqu'on parle de la moitié du XXᵉ siècle, à la Deuxième Guerre mondiale, le développement des sciences médicales ?
C'est clair qu'il y a un continuum en termes de progrès techniques et médicaux qui jouent un rôle. Ce qui est frappant,
je n'en fais pas une preuve, mais c'est quand même un indice, c'est que Riesman, dans le livre que j'évoquais tout à l'heure, La foule solitaire,
situait aussi aux alentours de la Deuxième Guerre mondiale, le moment où cette introdétermination, cet individualisme très normé vers des aspirations forcément édifiantes
dont on a parlé, commençait à laisser la place à un nouveau type d'individu.
Et la description qu'en donnait déjà Riesman en 50 est assez proche de la description qu'en donne Yonnet en 2006. Donc ces deux auteurs ont vraiment une convergence sur l'idée qu'un basculement s'opère dans la période d'après Seconde Guerre mondiale.
Je dirais que la décennie la plus symptomatique du changement, c'est 1960.
Mh.
Et ce changement va cristalliser de manière spectaculaire dans Mai 68. Pourquoi est-ce que cette double révolution démographique conduit à une forme d'individualisme ?
L'idée de Yonnet, c'est qu'un enfant aujourd'hui naît dans une condition doublement nouvelle. Il n'est plus marqué par la crainte de la mort.
Il n'est plus menacé par le risque de disparaître à cinq ans, dix ans. Il ne voit plus dans sa famille, sauf dans des cas très exceptionnels, un de ses grands frères ou une de ses grandes sœurs disparaître prématurément.
Il ne voit pas ses parents ou d'autres membres proches de la famille disparaître prématurément. Il n'y a plus cette idée qu'on est un numéro dans une lignée qui vient remplacer l'un ou l'autre enfant mort-né ou mort trop tôt
et qui va, aussi, ce numéro, devoir se consacrer à la survie de cette lignée.
Nous sommes sûrs de notre solidité physiologique. Nous sommes sûrs que nous allons vivre jusqu'à septante, quatre-vingt ans, voire au-delà.
Nous sommes débarrassés de la mort,
qui était, dit Yonnet, la grande éducatrice qui nous rappelait la fragilité de l'existence, qui nous rappelait une certaine humilité, qui nous rappelait que nous étions précaires et que nous devions
continuer à obéir au groupe pour tirer de cette appartenance au groupe des lignes de défense face à cette menace permanente de la mort.
Dans l'Antiquité, Montaigne encore aussi, Platon avant, disait que la philosophie, c'est apprendre à mourir. Aujourd'hui, la philosophie, c'est apprendre à vivre, c'est apprendre à s'épanouir.
Et d'autant plus, ajoute Yonnet, qu'avec le contrôle des naissances,
on quitte le schéma de familles assez nombreuses et dans lesquelles les enfants sont destinés à maintenir la lignée de génération en génération pour poursuivre cette sorte d'accomplissement qu'évoquait Riesman.
On n'a plus désormais qu'un tout petit nombre d'enfants. On est à une moyenne d'1,5 enfant par femme, donc en deçà en fait du seuil de reproduction des générations.
Et ces enfants sont des enfants désormais qui sont voulus. Qui sont choisis, qui viennent au moment où les parents les souhaitent, puisqu'il y a, pour tous ceux qui les souhaitent et sont très nombreux,
une maîtrise à peu près absolue de la conception grâce à la contraception.
Les enfants ne sont plus là par accident, ils sont le résultat d'un projet.
Ils ne naissent plus par accident biologique. Il n'y a presque plus d'enfants, en tout cas beaucoup moins qu'avant, qui naissent de manière involontaire.
Ils ne sont pas la conséquence naturelle du fait qu'on s'est marié et que donc avec le mariage, on entame des relations sexuelles qui conduisent à faire naître des enfants.
Yonnet observe que la séquence traditionnelle s'est modifiée. Ça n'est plus le mariage, puis la sexualité, puis les enfants.
C'est souvent le couple avec sa sexualité, puis les enfants et puis éventuellement après, on se marie parce que dans la perspective de l'héritage, il vaut quand même mieux être marié.
Faire naître des enfants qui sont voulus et qui sont délivrés de la hantise de la mort comme leurs parents aussi le sont, c'est faire naître, dit Yonnet, d'authentiques individus
dont on va valoriser l'autonomie, la singularité et qu'on va élever de manière radicalement nouvelle.
Il y a des pages très éloquentes de Yonnet sur la révolution de l'éducation.
L'enfant n'est plus celui dont on s'empare pour, sur la base d'une éducation très stricte, très rigide, très longue, l'amener à se conformer à cette règle d'une vie édifiante et ascensionnelle.
C'est un enfant qu'on va éduquer de manière horizontale, souple et bienveillante, pas de manière verticale, rigide et autoritaire.
On va l'amener à cultiver son autonomie, son épanouissement, choisir sa voie. C'est une éducation que les critiques appellent laxiste ou trop libérale,
que ceux qui la défendent considèrent comme beaucoup plus épanouissante et respectueuse de la personnalité.
Les parents ont voulu cet enfant et donc ils veulent son bonheur. Et donc en interdisant, en encadrant ses désirs à lui, son bonheur à lui, finalement, ils renient leurs propres souhaits, leurs propres projets.
Et donc voilà, ils sont, disons, amenés à permettre plus, beaucoup plus grande liberté que ce que eux-mêmes avaient connu—
Pour ceux de la première génération de parents de ce type, oui. Et aujourd'hui, nous sommes au moins à la troisième génération.
Les jeunes aujourd'hui, ce sont des enfants nés de parents qui sont eux-mêmes nés déjà de cette révolution démographique.
Oui, bien sûr.
Ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui, les jeunes parents, ils ont déjà baigné dans ces évidences qui sont singularité, autonomie, émancipation, réalisation de soi.
Et donc on baigne aujourd'hui dans un univers fait d'une remarquable bienveillance, d'où cette campagne d'affichage de la STIB que j'évoquais tout à l'heure : Rêveur, rêveuse, c'est toi que nous attendons.
À l'époque de l'introdétermination, on n'aurait pas pu imaginer une seule seconde de s'adresser à des jeunes de cette manière-là et de valoriser leur indétermination, leur inachèvement.
Un concept qui marque plutôt le travail de Paul Yonnet, c'est alors l'extrodétermination.
Alors ça, c'est l'élément le plus interpellant, sans doute, de la théorie de Yonnet. En fait, le terme d'extrodétermination, c'est un terme de Riesman dans La foule solitaire,
mais qu'on peut appliquer avec quelques nuances, mais très réellement au schéma de Yonnet.
Donc, je l'exprime dans les termes de Yonnet qui sont plus simples. L'idée de Yonnet, c'est qu'on commet une erreur majeure et très fréquente en considérant que l'individualisme, c'est un souci exclusif de soi-même,
que l'individualiste est forcément un narcissique.
Mh.
Quelqu'un qui s'aime et qui, du coup, peut ignorer les autres ou ne pas se préoccuper des autres. Narcisse, selon la légende, c'est celui qui est tombé amoureux de son reflet qu'il voyait dans l'eau
au point de, pour s'approcher de son visage et l'embrasser, tomber dans l'eau et se noyer.
Pour Yonnet, l'individu contemporain n'est pas narcissique. Il n'est pas coupé des autres. Il ne s'affirme pas contre les autres ou sans les autres, malgré les autres.
Il est né, au contraire, du désir des autres. Cet enfant qui a été voulu par ses parents, qui ont cherché à concevoir un ou deux enfants, le plus souvent, pas plus, à tel moment qu'ils l'ont attendu,
qui ont revendiqué de pouvoir faire naître leur enfant, même s'il s'agit d'un couple de personnes de même sexe, même s'il s'agit d'un couple dont l'un ou l'autre est infertile et qui doit passer par la PMA ou la fécondation in vitro.
Cet enfant est un enfant qui a été dès le début
baigné dans la bienveillance, dans l'attente, dans l'amour, dans l'accompagnement de ses parents,
qui a ressenti ce lien extrêmement fort, beaucoup plus affectif, beaucoup plus attentif, notamment de la part des pères qui ont une autre présence aujourd'hui et un autre rôle que ce qu'on a connu auparavant.
Et donc c'est un enfant qui est en fait créé par les autres, par leur désir parental de le faire naître. Il a bénéficié de tout cet accompagnement qui l'a conduit, qui l'a encouragé à cultiver son épanouissement, ses désirs, sa singularité.
Et donc, il devient en fait dépendant de ce rapport
de bienveillance et de reconnaissance apporté par sa famille.
Et il devient donc, du coup, y compris comme jeune et puis comme adulte, toujours soucieux des autres, toujours soucieux de leur reconnaissance, toujours soucieux de leur approbation, toujours soucieux de leur bienveillance.
Ce n'est pas un hasard si en philosophie, les théories de la reconnaissance sont nées il y a quelques décennies et sont aujourd'hui extrêmement présentes dans le champ intellectuel.
Ça n'est pas un hasard. Si les minorités de toute nature, minorités sexuelles, les femmes en tant qu'elles ont été minorisées, même si elles étaient les plus nombreuses,
les personnes transgenres, les minorités issues de l'immigration, les minorités culturelles ont revendiqué l'égalité des droits.
Ces dernières décennies. Parce que quand vous êtes né dans cette atmosphère de bienveillance, de reconnaissance inconditionnelle de la valeur de chacun, parce que tous les jeunes êtres humains sont,
sont censés avoir été voulus, avoir été désirés, et que vous constatez qu'il y a malgré tout des inégalités juridiques ou des discriminations, vous êtes armés pour revendiquer l'égalité des droits.
Mais ce n'est pas seulement une égalité de droits, c'est aussi une demande de reconnaissance. On veut que le regard de l'autre change.
Et donc c'est un individu qui est extrodéterminé, dit Riesman, qui se détermine en fonction des autres, qui est soucieux des autres, alors qu'un individu introdéterminé est plutôt un cynique qui ne se préoccupe guère des autres.
Alors, c'est absolument fascinant. Je reviens juste sur le point que vous avez évoqué il y a un instant.
Vous donniez une définition du narcissisme en vous basant, voilà, donc sur le mythe de Narcisse, donc de l'Antiquité, donc qui est là effectivement l'autoérotisme.
On tombe amoureux de son propre reflet, de soi-même, on ne se concentre que sur sa propre personne. Et c'est intéressant parce que la définition aujourd'hui en sciences psychologiques, c'est plutôt de dire
: le narcissique veut en permanence être sous le spotlight, au centre de l'attention.
Il veut qu'on ne regarde que lui. Et quand on parle de quelqu'un d'autre, il est fou de rage. Non, non, il faut parler de moi, surtout pas des autres.
Et donc là, on est en fait à fond dans ce que vous venez de décrire. Voilà, ce besoin de validation de notre société.
Du coup, je vous pose la question : si on vit dans une société individualiste extrodéterminée, est-ce qu'il y a une épidémie de narcissisme ?
Si vous prenez le narcissisme au sens le plus étroit, celui du mythe de Narcisse, Yonnet vous répondrait non.
Mh.
Ce n'est pas de l'auto-amour dans l'ignorance—
Ouais.
...des autres. Par contre, si vous le prenez dans un sens plus large, plus courant,
si vous considérez que le narcissique, c'est celui qui se considère avec fierté, qui se préoccupe de son image, de sa réputation, qui
tire une jouissance de sa supériorité, de sa beauté, de son style et qui, du coup, a besoin de l'approbation d'autrui pour se faire confirmer cette singularité ou cette excellence, alors en effet, nous avons une épidémie de narcissisme
dont on peut considérer qu'un phénomène typiquement contemporain comme le selfie est une des illustrations.
Non pas parce qu'on a envie de se regarder soi-même dans son reflet, de se prendre en photo et de s'admirer, mais—
Tout à fait.
...de se montrer à autrui sur Instagram.
Le phénomène fondamental, ça n'est pas qu'on se prend en photo, c'est que cette photo, on l'envoie sur les réseaux sociaux—
Ouais.
...et qu'on se préoccupe du nombre de likes, du nombre d'approbations qu'on reçoit. Ce qui est un phénomène que Yonnet avait non pas traité parce qu'il achève son livre en 2004,
il le publie en 2006 et il mourra en 2011 d'une maladie très invalidante, mais il avait bien perçu le début du phénomène des réseaux sociaux, cette
préoccupation majeure du regard d'autrui.
Et en plus, il avait déjà bien compris ce que l'informatique apportait. Il y a quelques pages dans son livre pleines de prescience qui développent l'idée que les réseaux sociaux nous apportent l'idée d'une situation idéale de proximité éloignée.
C'est-à-dire, je suis proche d'autrui, je suis en communication, on se parle, on se voit, on se filme, mais nous sommes à distance.
C'est-à-dire que je suis protégé. Ce regard de l'autre dont j'ai besoin,
comme de pain, parce qu'il doit contribuer à maintenir à l'âge de l'adolescence, puis à l'âge adulte, ce regard bienveillant des parents, ce regard des autres, en même temps, c'est toujours un risque.
Je peux, on le sait, être harcelé, je peux être critiqué, je peux être moqué, je peux être agressé. Je ne suis pas à l'aise devant ce risque que je prends quand je me montre,
lors d'une fête d'anniversaire, embrassant mon chéri ou ma chérie avec ma nouvelle tenue dont je suis très fier.
Je me demande si je vais être approuvé ou pas. Et donc, Yonnet avait bien compris que l'intérêt des réseaux sociaux, c'est qu'on restait physiquement à distance, temporellement aussi.
Je lance sur le net, sur les réseaux dont je suis membre, l'image de moi dont je veux mesurer le succès.
Ouais, une communication contrôlée.
Et puis quand le premier retour arrive, personne n'est là pour voir comment je réagis. Si je suis décontenancé, inquiet, choqué, peiné, j'ai encore le temps de me reprendre et de réfléchir à une riposte.
Oui.
On n'oserait pas faire en face à face ce qu'on se risque à faire sur le net parce qu'il y a cette distance proximité éloignée.
C'est ça. Alors, on va explorer encore un peu plus les questions liées aux réseaux sociaux, aux smartphones, etc. tout à l'heure quand on explorera, voilà, les travaux de Twenge avec vous.
Mais avant ça, si je reviens donc et que je combine les deux éléments que nous avons mentionnés, à savoir les réseaux sociaux et, voilà, cette épidémie de narcissisme, pour appeler ça comme ça, hein, même si c'est un petit peu,
un petit peu simpliste.
Un sujet qu'on avait exploré avec Olivier Klein dans le podcast, il me semble que c'était en mai dernier, donc relativement tôt dans la pandémie, c'était la question du complotisme.
Et Olivier Klein donnait plusieurs explications à ces phénomènes, hein, puisque comme on le sait,
c'est quelque chose qu'on a beaucoup observé, en particulier lors de cette pandémie, des explications absolument fausses liées au vaccin, liées à la maladie, voilà, des complots,
comme quoi ce serait lié à Bill Gates, au gouvernement français, voilà, ou je ne sais quoi.
Une des explications qu'Olivier Klein nous donnait, c'était que,
l'individu complotiste est une personne qui recherche une forme d'unicité, recherche à être spécial, à se démarquer des autres en disant : « Mais regarde, moi, j'ai compris comment c'est vraiment.
J'ai compris la vraie vérité vraie. Moi, je sais que en fait, le vaccin, il contient des micropuces, que en fait, le virus, il a été créé de toutes pièces en Chine » et ainsi de suite.
Et donc, je peux téléphoner à ma famille, téléphoner à mes amis et me valoriser en disant : « Mais moi, je sais, je peux te faire voir la vraie vérité vraie. »
Il y a toujours eu des rumeurs, il y a toujours eu une sorte de sagesse populaire—
Oui.
...de méfiance à l'égard des grands. C'étaient les ministres du roi que l'on critiquait, mais on n'était pas forcément toujours très confiant à l'égard du roi lui-même.
Cela étant, il est clair que le complotisme prend aujourd'hui des formes plus aiguës et sans doute plus répandues.
Et je pense qu'il peut y avoir un rapport avec l'individualisme. Je voudrais le mettre quand même en deux mots en perspective, parce que ce qui personnellement me frappe, c'est que l'individualisme semble être à la source, à la fois
de bienveillance et d'arrogance.
J'ai déjà dit quelques mots de la bienveillance, ces stratégies de reconnaissance, toutes ces politiques typiquement contemporaines qui accordent des droits égaux à toutes ces minorités qui pendant longtemps étaient ignorées ou bafouées ou méprisées.
C'est dans la droite ligne de l'individualisme tel que Yonnet le développe. Les individus sont des individus voulus, des individus dont la singularité, a priori, était admise.
Et vous avez à la naissance un enfant frappé d'un handicap ou d'une difficulté particulière, eh bien peu importe. C'est un être singulier comme d'autres.
On ne dit d'ailleurs plus aujourd'hui les handicapés, on parle de personnes en situation de handicap, pour bien dire que ce sont des personnes à part entière.
Alors, ça ne s'est pas fait tout seul. Il a fallu des revendications, mais pour que la revendication prenne, il fallait bien être dans cette atmosphère globale de reconnaissance de la dignité inconditionnelle de tout le monde.
Et donc, il y a cette forte dimension de bienveillance, mais en même temps, on a parlé du narcissisme, c'est clair qu'éduquer des enfants en les encourageant à l'autonomie,
à la critique des autorités, en leur faisant comprendre qu'ils ont une grande liberté de choix, en instituant dans les rapports intrafamiliaux beaucoup plus d'égalité.
Les parents se laissent beaucoup plus critiquer, interpeller, bousculer. La famille devient un espace de négociation permanent où la moindre règle est contestée pied à pied par les enfants.
Et les parents se sentent souvent obligés de justifier la règle pour l'imposer ou de renoncer à la règle s'ils ne se sentent pas capables de l'argumenter.
Il est paru il y a quelques années en France un livre tout à fait symptomatique de l'époque dont le titre est « Devenez meilleur négociateur que vos enfants ».
Et donc ces enfants-là, ça peut devenir des narcissiques ou ça peut devenir des enfants rois qui vont vouloir imposer leur toute-puissance en permanence.
Et ça peut devenir donc aussi des êtres arrogants, sûrs de leur supériorité, qui ne reconnaissent aucune forme d'autorité parce qu'ils veulent toujours être leur propre maître et leur propre juge.
On vit dans une culture de la critique permanente et de la mise en question de toutes les autorités, ce qui est très sain.
C'est un combat fondamental qui a été mené pendant quelques siècles et qui est une des sources de l'installation, évidemment, de la démocratie,
qui veut que tout un chacun ait le droit de vote et le droit d'éligibilité, c'est-à-dire que nous soyons égaux.
Mais on voit bien en quoi tout ça peut conduire éventuellement à un excès d'arrogance
et à la volonté pour un individu de se démarquer des autres en se montrant plus lucide, plus intelligent,
au courant, au fait de vérités cachées que lui est parvenu à découvrir dans les bons réseaux de communication, alors que les autres sont des moutons qui les ignorent.
Mh.
Et donc, de fait, je pense qu'il doit y avoir un lien entre l'expansion du conspirationnisme et l'individualisme tel que Yonnet l'analyse.
Mais ce n'est sans doute pas loin de là la seule—
Non. Et effectivement—
...cause du développement du phénomène.
Olivier Klein donnait effectivement plusieurs pistes d'explication. Donc voilà, c'est assez clair à ce niveau-là. Et donc, si je reviens à ce qu'on évoquait, le monde d'avant qui était très prétracé.
Finalement, rien de plus simple que d'éduquer un enfant, puisqu'on fait comme j'ai moi-même été éduqué, comme mon père a lui-même été éduqué et ainsi de suite.
Si on observe cette transition comme étant la démultiplication des possibilités, on peut remettre en question ses parents, on peut remettre en question l'ordre établi.
Si je vous demande d'analyser à travers ce prisme-là la question de la Belgique pilarisée.
Oui, le mouvement démarre de manière flagrante dans les années septante, pour ne pas remonter plus loin. En 1960, en Flandre, le Parti catholique faisait encore cinquante pour cent des voix.
Dans ce mouvement de dépilarisation, le phénomène le plus frappant, et ça ne vaut pas du tout que pour la Belgique, c'est la perte d'influence des partis de tradition chrétienne
et, de manière tout à fait concomitante, la perte d'influence de l'Église.
On sait bien que la pratique religieuse a chuté de manière spectaculaire au fil des dernières décennies dans la plupart des pays d'Europe de l'Ouest,
que le degré d'observance ou de respect des préceptes de l'Église catholique est devenu presque fantomatique.
Toute une série de personnes qui sont encore catholiques de cœur ou pratiquantes ont en même temps une distance critique à l'égard de certains dogmes qui sont encore
maintenus et défendus par l'Église sur la question de l'avortement, de l'euthanasie, du divorce, etc.
Il y a beaucoup de libertés qui ont été prises par rapport à la vérité défendue par l'institution elle-même.
Et donc ce n'est certainement pas un hasard. En France, on a publié il y a deux ans à peu près maintenant un livre remarquable de Jérôme Fourquet, qui s'appelle L'Archipel français,
qui commence par une centaine de pages d'examens sur une base statistique,
de l'évolution des valeurs et des comportements.
Et il fait le constat de ce qu'il appelle la dislocation de la matrice catholique. Tout ce qui modelait le système de pensée sur une base catholique s'effondre de génération en génération.
Et les différences entre les opinions ne s'expliquent pas par des milieux sociaux ou des appartenances, mais simplement par la génération.
Vous trouvez encore chez les plus âgés un nombre assez important de personnes qui restent fidèles à des vieux schémas autour du mariage, de la fidélité conjugale, une méfiance à l'égard du divorce, de l'avortement, de l'euthanasie, etc.
Et puis chez les jeunes, tout ça a quasi totalement disparu. Et donc c'est évidemment en ligne directe avec ce qu'on évoquait avec Lionel.
Quand vous êtes éduqué dans une atmosphère
de bienveillance, d'encouragement à l'autonomie, au choix personnel de vos valeurs, de vos parcours de vie, vous êtes éduqué par des parents qui ne vont pas vous dire en même temps : « Tu vas continuer à aller à la messe avec nous tous les dimanches
et puis tu vas faire forcément ta communion et puis tu te marieras forcément avant de t'installer en couple et ce sera forcément à l'église que tu te marieras en plus de la maison communale.
» Le mode d'éducation ayant changé, le pilier catholique, pour en tout cas la dimension de respect des règles religieuses, s'effondre et le vote catholique, du coup, s'étiole aussi.
Mais on a bien vu que d'autres piliers étaient effectivement mis en difficulté, qu'en fait, de plus en plus, les individus vont chercher,
de manière très individuelle à avoir la meilleure mutuelle, le meilleur hôpital, la meilleure école, indépendamment de l'héritage idéologique parental.
Ce pilier socialiste est aussi en crise. Et il y a de plus en plus de personnes qui ne vont pas suivre ce parcours traditionnel de socialiste, même si elles sont nées dans une famille où la tradition socialiste a été assez forte.
C'est la volonté même des parents de reproduire leur schéma et de l'imposer aux enfants qui a disparu très très largement.
Oui.
Et donc quand les parents ne se font pas des relais autoritaires, patients au quotidien de leur propre héritage, cet héritage, en quelques générations, il se dissipe et surtout la dimension de cet héritage qui vous obligerait à obéir
aux consignes, à obéir aux autorités.
Aujourd'hui, dans tous les partis politiques, quasiment sans exception, il est évident qu'on élit le président.
Un phénomène relativement récent qu'on observe aussi, ce sont des mutualités, des centres de planning familial
qui se disent libres, donc pluriculturels, pas spécifiques, pas spécifiquement attachés au pilier catholique, libéral, socialiste ou quoi, etc.
Donc ça va effectivement dans le sens de ce que vous disiez. J'aimerais revenir sur un point que vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure.
Vous avez parlé d'un lien qu'on pouvait faire entre l'individualisme et la crise de la démocratie que nous connaissons actuellement.
Alors, il y a plusieurs éléments d'explication possibles. D'abord, toute cette atmosphère de célébration de nos choix, de notre autonomie, de notre volonté, de notre singularité,
ça vous conduit assez naturellement à considérer que la démocratie devrait servir à satisfaire vos choix, vos valeurs, vos préférences.
Il est devenu de plus en plus difficile, Lionel explique, de plaider en faveur d'un intérêt général au nom duquel vous devriez sacrifier vos préférences ou vos intérêts particuliers.
Puis, je pointerais au moins une deuxième dimension de la crise de la démocratie liée à l'individualisme, c'est que les figures d'autorité n'ont plus l'évidence ou l'aura qu'elles pouvaient posséder auparavant.
Puisque précisément, encore une fois, on cultive l'autonomie, la liberté de choix, la liberté de critique, l'affirmation de sa propre singularité.
Ça vous conduit à être beaucoup moins réceptif à l'idée que votre choix pourrait être subitement dévié ou nié par une autorité supérieure qui, dans le domaine politique, vous dirait : « Ce qu'il convient de faire, c'est ceci.
Et parce que je suis président de parti ou ministre ou Premier ministre, je l'impose. » Et la discussion, fondamentalement, est nulle et non avenue.
On ne voudrait pas caricaturer,
ce qu'a été la vie politique à une certaine époque, mais on a connu l'époque où on considérait qu'il y avait des hommes d'État,
pas des femmes, évidemment, des hommes d'État qui, par leur carrière, par leur mérite, avaient acquis un prestige tel que leur parole était censée avoir un poids particulier.
Aujourd'hui, en Belgique, vous ne verrez pas un président de parti ou un Premier ministre, sauf exception, s'exprimer avec cet aplomb comme s'il avait la certitude d'une supériorité et du fait que les troupes vont suivre.
Le président de parti, le Premier ministre, le ministre va montrer au contraire à quel point il est au service de la population, à l'écoute des critiques.
Et il se présente comme un primus inter pares : « Je suis celui qui va essayer d'aménager les choses au mieux à votre profit, mais je ne suis plus une autorité », au sens classique du terme.
Et donc la crise de la représentation, c'est aussi le refus d'admettre que tel ou tel, parce qu'il est professionnel de la politique et qu'il a une longue expérience, a forcément une supériorité sur moi-même.
En fait, il y a crise de la représentation parce qu'il n'y a plus le fossé social et le fossé symbolique
entre les élus qui faisaient partie des élites et un peuple qui pouvait modestement considérer que d'autres sont plus compétents, plus savants, ont une expérience supérieure, une plus grande sagesse.
Chacun aujourd'hui ou presque se sent l'égal-
Mh.
...d'un responsable politique de premier plan. Et on le voit dans la manière dont certains s'adressent aux responsables politiques, alors avec éventuellement violence ou irrespect, ou tout simplement une forme d'égalité vécue comme une évidence.
Quand vous voyez des jeunes filles,
Greta Thunberg ou d'autres, en tête à tête avec Ursula von der Leyen, présidente de la Commission européenne, vous voyez des adolescentes s'adresser à la personne la plus influente sur le continent européen
sans avoir l'air d'être particulièrement impressionnées.
Parce qu'on vit dans ce bain d'horizontalité qui est assez radicalement nouveau par rapport à ce qu'on a connu jusqu'il y a quelques décennies.
Si je pense à des situations comme celles qu'on connaît en Russie, par exemple, ou en Chine, la Chine pas très individualiste,
on voit que les démocraties ont évolué différemment en fonction de l'histoire, en fonction des cultures à travers le monde.
Incontestablement, le schéma que défend Yonnet, qui est basé sur des observations historiques, repose essentiellement sur l'aire géographique qu'est l'Europe de l'Ouest et plus particulièrement, dans son cas, la France.
Celui de Riesman, basculant de l'autodétermination à l'extradétermination, vaut aussi pour l'Europe de l'Ouest, pour l'Amérique du Nord.
Il ne prétend pas pouvoir l'appliquer de manière simple au reste de la planète. Il est frappant de voir qu'on a quand même des mouvements d'une nature manifestement très proche dans toute une série de zones.
Si vous pensez, par exemple, aux pays d'Amérique latine qui sont pionniers ou très en pointe sur la reconnaissance des droits des minorités sexuelles, des personnes transgenres, le mariage entre personnes de même sexe.
On voit bien que ça n'est pas seulement une affaire, je dirais, du noyau dur du monde occidental.
Par contre, il est bien clair qu'un pays très industrialisé, qui a lui aussi opéré la double révolution démographique, recul de la mort et diminution drastique du nombre de naissances comme le Japon,
garde des codes sociaux beaucoup plus stricts, beaucoup plus respectueux d'un certain nombre de règles de convenance, de politesse et que donc ça ne se joue pas de la même manière.
Il y a des particularités nationales dont je ne suis pas du tout,
infamilier. Il est bien clair qu'on ne peut pas plaquer sur la planète entière un schéma qui est élaboré par des intellectuels qui réfléchissent sur la base des États-Unis ou de la France.
Ça, il faut être conscient des limites du modèle.
Voilà pour la crise de la démocratie. Si on s'approche d'une autre question qui est
le libéralisme, le néolibéralisme et par exemple, en particulier les années 80, donc les années Reagan, les années Thatcher, où voilà, l'idée, c'est vraiment que l'individu est maître, qu'il y a assez peu
de restrictions, assez peu d'encadrement vis-à-vis de ses obligations.
Est-ce que vous mettez ça à nouveau en lien avec l'individualisme ?
Je ne mettrais pas cela directement en lien avec l'individualisme parce que
c'est un vieux combat idéologique qui oppose les tenants d'un libéralisme pur et dur, qui laisse un maximum de liberté aux entreprises, qui diminue
la protection sociale offerte aux personnes parce qu'il faut impérativement d'abord diminuer le niveau d'imposition, le niveau de taxation.
Ça, c'est un projet idéologique lié au fonctionnement de l'économie qui a, je dirais, sa vie propre. Par contre, dans la période que vous évoquez, il y a un phénomène important et qui fait partie du débat sur l'individualisme,
qui est l'avènement d'un nouveau système managérial que Riesman observait déjà au début des années
50, fin des années 40, mais qui s'installe de manière vraiment massive dans les années 80 aux États-Unis, puis 90 en Europe.
Ce qu'on a appelé le nouveau management. Et là, il y a un lien avec l'individualisme parce qu'on voit les entreprises cultiver des valeurs typiquement individualistes.
On va dans les entreprises, pas toutes, mais un certain nombre, et notamment des entreprises d'une certaine taille,
essayer d'effacer, de réduire les figures du contrôle, de l'autorité, de l'imposition des ordres et valoriser l'autonomie, l'initiative, la motivation spontanée des collaborateurs.
Ce sont plus des employés, ce sont des collaborateurs. On va prétendre les traiter en égaux dans des équipes qui seront des équipes horizontales dans lesquelles les rapports hiérarchiques sont tout à fait adoucis, voire,
officiellement annihilés.
Ceux qui avant se seraient appelés des directeurs ou des contremaîtres ou des chefs,
on va les présenter comme des coachs ou comme des accompagnants qui vont jouer sur la motivation, sur la volonté d'accomplissement des individus qui vont se donner des projets qu'ils vont
élaborer ensemble dans une équipe horizontale pour atteindre des objectifs qu'ils auraient en quelque sorte définis par eux-mêmes.
Il y a tout un nouveau modèle managérial
qui a amené un certain nombre d'intellectuels de gauche à considérer qu'en fait, l'individualisme contemporain, toute cette théorie de l'autonomie, de la singularité, la culture de la personnalité,
était peut-être un phénomène idéologique très classique dans une perspective marxiste.
On transforme le mode de fonctionnement des entreprises et ça déteint sur les mentalités, sur les comportements en dehors du domaine de l'entreprise.
Comme si la sphère de la superstructure, pardon, dans le vieux vocabulaire marxiste, continue à suivre les évolutions qui s'opèrent d'abord dans la sphère de l'infrastructure économique et sociale.
Avec ce soupçon donc que l'individualisme, c'est un produit de la transformation de l'entreprise et que c'est une sorte de piège dans lequel on veut faire entrer les individus.
On aurait construit cette idéologie pour les amener à adhérer à ce nouveau mode de fonctionnement des entreprises qui fait que
on va plus courir le risque d'imposer des règles et du coup d'avoir des révoltes, mais on va plutôt amener une sorte d'adhésion de l'intérieur.
Alors là-dessus, je pense qu'il faut être très net. En tout cas, c'est ce que je plaide personnellement.
Un des livres clés qu'on emploie pour faire le lien entre ce nouveau mode managérial et l'individualisme contemporain, c'est le livre de Luc Boltanski et Ève Chiapello qui s'appelle Le nouvel esprit du capitalisme.
Et souvent, on le présente comme la preuve que l'individualisme est né de cette révolution managériale à l'intérieur du monde de l'entreprise.
C'est tellement fréquent, cette interprétation, que dans une postface d'une réédition de leur livre, dans la collection Tel, Boltanski et Chiapello ont tenu à mettre les choses au point en disant : c'est totalement faux à nos yeux.
Ce qui se passe est très différent. Cette nouvelle valeur individualiste, elle précède de plusieurs décennies cette révolution managériale des années quatre-vingt et nonante.
La preuve, c'est Mai 68, où ces valeurs sont déjà très visiblement présentes. Donc la chronologie doit plutôt conduire à inverser le rapport de causalité.
C'est sans doute parce que la société est entrée dans cette ère individualiste qui devenait dominante que le monde de l'entreprise a dû se demander comment intégrer, comment tenir compte de cette
nouvelle mentalité, de ce nouveau système de valeurs, de ces nouveaux modes de comportement pour continuer à bien fonctionner.
Peut-on encore faire obéir
comme des moutons ou comme des personnes passives
des individus qui, au contraire, sont très convaincus de leur égalité foncière avec les autres, qui ne respectent plus spontanément l'autorité, qui croient aux vertus de leur créativité, de leur personnalité.
En plus, ajoutent Boltanski et Chiapello, il ne faut absolument pas croire qu'il y a une convergence parfaite entre l'individualisme tel qu'il démarre dans les années cinquante, soixante, septante, et ce nouveau mode de management.
Ils rappellent que l'individualisme, notamment autour de Mai 68, était un mouvement très subversif,
de mise en cause de toutes les autorités, y compris à l'intérieur des entreprises, y compris dans les églises, y compris dans les mouvements d'éducation permanente ou dans le monde syndical,
où là aussi, les figures de l'autorité déjà commençaient à être contestées,
notamment, mais pas seulement, par les femmes et par les jeunes.
Et donc la thèse de Boltanski et Chiapello est plutôt que le monde de l'entreprise a récupéré à son profit la partie de cette mentalité individualiste qui pouvait le servir.
Il peut être intéressant de se reposer sur
l'autodétermination, la volonté de créativité, d'implication
des salariés individualistes de nouvelles manières, de leur dire : on ne va pas vous imposer, on vous fixe un objectif très global et puis allez-y, créez, inventez, motivez-vous, articulez-vous entre vous,
créez par vous-même les modes de coopération.
Pour l'entreprise, c'était une manière de rendre invisible la verticalité et les rapports de pouvoir et d'effacer ou de diminuer le risque d'une révolte puisque officiellement, tout est cool.
On connaît bien toutes les légendes qui circulent sur les start-up de la Silicon Valley où on arrive en tee-shirt, en basket, où il y a une table de ping-pong, où on bavarde autour d'un café, etc.
Donc pour l'entreprise, c'est intéressant de récupérer ces valeurs d'horizontalité et d'auto-implication. Mais par contre, on n'a pas pris en compte la totalité du discours de l'individualisme, notamment la recherche de sens purement personnel,
et le refus radical de l'autorité que certains pourraient manifester.
Et on voit un certain nombre de personnes, notamment chez les jeunes, qui ont tâté de ces nouveaux modèles managériaux et puis qui en sont sortis parce qu'ils ont compris qu'en fait, derrière cette ouverture d'esprit,
il y a quand même l'imposition d'objectifs finaux extrêmement précis et la mise à la porte si on n'est pas à la hauteur.
Donc, le rapport entre individualisme et nouveau capitalisme est complexe. Et personnellement, là, je plaiderais,
alors que j'ai dit en début d'interview que j'étais assez marqué par la tradition marxiste, là, je plaiderais pour qu'on reconnaisse
le fait que cette nouvelle mentalité n'est pas forcément directement due à une transformation économique.
À voir, parce que Riesman, lui, fait le lien d'une manière un peu plus classiquement matérialiste. C'est un dossier, en tout cas, qui reste ouvert.
Mais donc pour appuyer cette idée qu'il y a une forme de récupération par le capitalisme de ce besoin d'unicité, ce besoin d'individualité,
un exemple que je trouve très intéressant, c'est quand on parle du manque de diversité dans le monde de l'entreprise, le manque de femmes, le manque de personnes racisées et ainsi de suite,
il y a toujours, c'est intéressant à observer, deux pistes pour arriver à
la conclusion qu'il faut plus de diversité.
C'est d'une part la justice sociale et d'autre part, le fait de dire : mais attendez,
si on a plus de diversité au sein de nos équipes, à ce moment-là, on a une richesse agrandie, plus de points de vue différents et donc plus de chances d'arriver à trouver la meilleure solution qui sera la plus rentable, la plus efficace, etc.
Et plus une implication volontaire aussi-
Voilà.
...de la part des salariés qui sont reconnaissants de la place qui leur est faite, oui.
Très intéressant. Donc cette question, le lien entre capitalisme et l'individualisme. Alors, on a évoqué tout à l'heure la fameuse question des selfies, la fameuse question des réseaux sociaux.
On a parfois pu entendre que
la dépression était une pathologie emblématique de notre époque, précisément à cause
des réseaux sociaux, à cause du fait que cette communication très contrôlée de soi-même, les photos qu'on poste, où on apparaît sous le meilleur jour possible sur Facebook, sur Instagram, etc.
Eh bien, pour le spectateur qui reste tout seul chez lui, en plein confinement, et qui observe tout ça, ça peut amener à une comparaison qui est très,
très violente, et ça peut amener alors potentiellement à la dépression.
Est-ce que vous avez un mot sur le lien entre dépression et individualisme ?
C'est un très bon sujet, c'est un sujet complexe. Je ne suis absolument pas médecin. Je crois qu'il faut quand même mettre de côté les dépressions endogènes,
ce qu'on appelait la maniacodépression, aujourd'hui les états bipolaires, ça, c'est une cause.
Voilà, bien sûr.
Et ne parler ici que des dépressions exogènes qui sont plutôt liées au rapport de l'individu à son environnement, à son expérience de vie, à ses contemporains.
Il y a deux liens qu'on peut faire.
Dans un mouvement d'idées assez proche de celui de Yonnet, il y a un sociologue
français, Alain Ehrenberg, qui a publié en nonante-huit un livre qui s'appelait La fatigue d'être soi, et Yonnet y fait référence dans ses travaux,
et qui défendait l'idée que la dépression était une conséquence de cet individualisme contemporain au sens où,
et c'est un point qu'on n'a pas encore abordé, on dit à cet individualiste qu'il peut être autonome, choisir par lui-même, etc.
Mais on lui dit aussi qu'il doit réussir sa vie,
qu'il doit s'épanouir, qu'il doit être heureux, qu'il doit tirer de ses propres ressources, de ses propres capacités, les moyens de,
réussir sa vie, qu'il ne peut pas être dépendant, qu'il ne peut pas être un parasite, qu'il doit être l'architecte de son existence, qu'il doit
cultiver son développement personnel.
Il y a une injonction qui nous est faite en permanence, non pas à vivre d'un bonheur tranquille, à cultiver notre jardin, mais à prouver aux autres et à se prouver à soi-même
qu'on tire les meilleurs bénéfices de nos ressources, de notre personnalité, de notre moi profond.
On ne nous laisse pas tranquille. On nous demande de montrer que nous sommes des individus pleinement accomplis.
Et donc, Ehrenberg développe l'idée que c'est un piège pour l'individu qui se sentirait incapable de satisfaire à cette injonction sociale,
qui verrait qu'il mène une vie assez médiocre, qui se sent dépendant des autres, qui n'est pas sur une trajectoire d'ascension sociale, qui ne s'enrichit pas, qui n'est pas heureux en ménage, dont la sexualité n'est pas ce formidable
moment sans cesse répété de jouissance extraordinaire.
Les personnes qui ne se sentent pas à la hauteur de cette injonction de bonheur peuvent alors sombrer dans une dépression dont Ehrenberg montre de manière très documentée que c'est en effet un phénomène qui explose quantitativement dans
le troisième tiers du vingtième siècle et qui a à voir avec l'individualisme. C'est un volet.
Un autre volet qui est très longuement documenté dans un livre qui est Génération Internet d'une chercheuse psychologue américaine, Jean Twenge, fait là le lien avec un autre phénomène qui a aussi rapport avec l'individualisme, qui est
l'importance des réseaux sociaux, du smartphone dans la vie des jeunes.
Twenge a étudié sur la longue durée des enquêtes statistiques qui répètent
depuis des décennies les mêmes questions qu'on adresse aux générations successives de jeunes, ce qui permet de comparer en quoi les jeunes d'aujourd'hui se distinguent éventuellement des jeunes d'hier.
Pas des aînés, parce que ça, c'est clair qu'il y a des distinctions, mais des jeunes des générations précédentes.
Et à son grand étonnement, elle a constaté qu'à partir de deux mille onze, deux mille douze, toute une série de courbes statistiques s'infléchissaient de manière durable et spectaculaire,
et notamment dans le sens de toute une série de symptômes de mal-être assez aigus chez les jeunes,
de mal-être dépressif, tentatives de suicide, suicide effectivement consommé, réussi ou non, mais effectivement tenté,
sentiment de solitude, sentiment d'abandon, sentiment de perte de confiance en soi, d'estime, etc.
Et les corrélations statistiques semblent sans appel. Ça correspond au moment où une nouvelle génération apparaît, qui a comme caractéristique qu'elle a un smartphone dans la main depuis les toutes premières années.
Et le phénomène ne fait que s'accentuer en Belgique. En quelques années, on est passé d'un âge moyen du premier smartphone qui était douze ans à un âge moyen qui est maintenant de neuf ans.
Et l'interprétation de Twenge, c'est que
c'est certainement ce surusage, qui est très documenté aussi, on connaît le nombre d'heures que certains jeunes peuvent passer sur leur smartphone et en particulier sur les réseaux sociaux,
c'est certainement ce surusage qui est une cause massive de l'augmentation de ces sentiments de mal-être.
Parce qu'on a pu plus finement montrer que ce sont spécifiquement dans la jeune génération ceux qui ont une consommation particulièrement élevée
du smartphone et des réseaux sociaux, qui y passent le plus de temps, qui déclarent le plus de symptômes de mal-être tels que je les ai développés.
Or, Twenge constate cela et ne se l'explique pas tout à fait clairement, même si elle donne un certain nombre de témoignages qui tracent un début de piste.
Si on repense à Yonnet, c'est très simple et c'est ce qu'on constate depuis quelques mois, malheureusement, avec le confinement sous ses diverses formes.
Nous avons besoin de rapports sociaux comme de pain. Nous sommes dépendants des autres, des contacts physiques, directs, affectifs, sexuels, amicaux, sociaux, de l'approbation, du dialogue, de la bienveillance.
En permanence, c'est vital.
Pourquoi physique et direct ?
Pardon ?
Parce que ce que vous pouvez obtenir à travers un smartphone ou un écran d'ordinateur, ce n'est qu'un ersatz. Ce sont des caresses virtuelles.
Ça n'est pas l'équivalent d'une vraie présence. C'est une communication appauvrie dans laquelle vous avez
une image, mais une image en deux dimensions, un dialogue verbal éventuellement, mais que vous décodez beaucoup plus difficilement parce que—
On n'est pas en face à face, on ne sait pas tirer profit de la même manière des expressions du visage, de la tonalité de la voix, à travers un écran, a fortiori un écran aussi petit que celui d'un smartphone,
parce qu'il reste cette dimension d'éloignement qu'évoquait Yonnet.
Vous êtes proches, mais en même temps, vous n'êtes pas en contact direct. On l'a suffisamment dit, on le sait maintenant clairement,
dans les effets psychologiques de la crise sanitaire, il y a l'interdiction de se voir, de se toucher pour les personnes âgées, d'avoir simplement un contact physique, une caresse sur la main, une embrassade, etc.
Ce que Twenge constate, c'est que ces jeunes qui sont sur les réseaux sociaux sont mis en difficulté parce que l'approbation qu'ils recherchent en permanence n'est pas garantie.
Ils s'interrogent avec anxiété sur leur nombre de likes et ce nombre de likes peut être faible. Ils ont besoin d'être approuvés, mais dans certains cas, au contraire, ils sont critiqués, voire harcelés.
Ils lancent un selfie ou une image comme une bouteille à la mer pour espérer une congratulation, mais dans certains cas, ils sont ignorés.
Ils sont aussi dans un piège, c'est qu'ils voient les autres donner de leur existence une image très flatteuse. Quand vous
montrez des images de votre vie quotidienne sur le Net, en règle générale, ce sont des moments de bonheur, ce sont des moments qui flattent votre beauté, votre choix vestimentaire.
En plus, ce n'est pas un hasard, on a développé des logiciels de retouche du visage, du maquillage, de votre silhouette qui font que les jeunes sont en permanence,
et elle a recueilli des témoignages, baignés dans l'idée que tous les autres sont formidables.
Tous les autres, à travers ce qu'ils montrent sur leurs réseaux sociaux, sont occupés à réussir leur vie, sont beaux, sont désirés, sont bien habillés, ont plein de succès, sont populaires, comme on dit aux États-Unis.
Et les jeunes vont se comparer à cette réussite éclatante.
Et si vous n'êtes pas vous-même bien armé au centre d'un tissu de relations très denses et très favorables, vous commencez à douter radicalement de vous-même et vous pouvez tomber dans des formes diverses et variées de dépression.
Donc, il semble qu'il y a un lien entre surusage
des réseaux sociaux et des symptômes de mal-être parce que nous sommes des individualistes contemporains à la Yonnet,
pas des narcissiques qui peuvent se contenter du rapport à eux-mêmes, mais des personnes éminemment dépendantes du jugement d'autrui.
Oui alors vous dites « des individualistes contemporains à la Yonnet ». Vous évoquiez tout à l'heure le fait qu'on est à présent au moins à la troisième génération de, voilà, de ce type d'individualistes.
Alors, j'ai envie de vous poser la question : est-ce que de la même manière qu'il y a eu
une première famille d'individualistes avec,
voilà, ce qu'on décrivait tout à l'heure, voilà, dans les travaux de David Riesman, fin du XIXe, début du XXe, avec ce modèle d'intro-détermination.
Et puis, ce que décrit Paul Yonnet à partir de la moitié du XXe siècle, l'extro-détermination. Est-ce qu'on n'arrive pas aujourd'hui à une nouvelle forme d'individualisme liée donc aux réseaux sociaux,
et à la nouvelle génération ?
Alors, c'est possible. Ça fait partie des interrogations que soulève ou qu'induit le livre de Twenge, qui est paru en 2017 aux États-Unis, en 2018, en français aux éditions Mardaga.
Elle fait un constat qui l'a troublée encore plus que ces symptômes de mal-être liés au smartphone, qu'elle s'expliquait assez bien.
Elle fait un autre constat massif, qui vaut en tout cas incontestablement pour les États-Unis, qui est un phénomène de retard de maturation.
Les jeunes aujourd'hui seraient en retard de deux, trois ans dans leur évolution, dans leur maturation par rapport aux jeunes des générations antérieures.
Là, elle ne cherche pas du tout à lier ça au smartphone. Elle observe d'ailleurs que ce retard de maturation s'esquissait déjà dans la génération précédente, ce qu'on appelait la génération des milléniaux. Et elle
n'en tire pas
une conclusion définitive. Elle est manifestement très déroutée
devant toute une série de symptômes qui indiquent que les jeunes aux États-Unis entrent plus tard dans des comportements caractéristiques de l'âge adulte ou des comportements caractéristiques de l'adolescence, en ce que
ce sont des moments où on s'affirme comme les adultes, où on prend le type d'autonomie ou d'indépendance propre aux adultes.
Il y a recul aux États-Unis sur tous ces plans, des pratiques sexuelles ou de l'âge du premier rapport sexuel, de la pratique de la boisson, de l'alcool, moins de jeunes qui travaillent pour se faire de l'argent de poche.
Les jeunes ne cherchent plus à obtenir un argent de poche mensuel qu'ils vont gérer par eux-mêmes. Ils demandent de l'argent au cas par cas.
Ils sont moins de sortie, en dehors du domicile. Ils sont plus cantonnés chez eux, moins de liberté. Ils revendiquent moins de liberté.
Ils cherchent beaucoup moins précocement à apprendre à conduire avec le symbole d'autonomie qu'est la capacité d'utiliser la voiture, etc., etc.
Il est assez difficile de prétendre que le même phénomène a déjà cours aujourd'hui en Belgique, en France, en Europe de l'Ouest.
Le tableau statistique, pour le peu que j'ai pu tenter de le vérifier, est un peu plus contrasté. On peut quand même se demander s'il n'y a pas une évolution en cours qui serait une sorte d'accentuation du mouvement évoqué par Yonnet. Une fois qu'on
quitte de plus en plus
le système de notre détermination, une fois qu'on n'éduque presque plus de jeunes dans ce schéma plus rigide,
plus contraint, dans lequel on force vraiment les jeunes à devenir indépendants, à puiser dans leurs propres ressources pour, de manière patiente et exigeante, réussir leurs études et puis réussir leur carrière.
Une fois qu'on est bien installé, au contraire, dans cette éducation beaucoup plus bienveillante, beaucoup plus patiente, beaucoup plus ouverte à la singularité. En fait, on n'encourage pas les jeunes à affirmer leur indépendance.
On connaît depuis longtemps ce qu'on appelle le phénomène Tanguy à la suite du film d'Étienne Chatiliez. Tanguy, qui à vingt-huit ans, était encore chez ses parents à poursuivre sa thèse de doctorat sur la Chine médiévale.
Les jeunes n'ont plus de raison d'abord de vouloir être indépendants très tôt parce qu'ils sont très bien dans la famille.
Et Twenge d'ailleurs relève que la famille est devenue pour eux un cocon. Pour les raisons que Yonnet met en évidence, on a beaucoup de liberté.
On peut recevoir son copain, sa copine, on est en famille presque comme à l'hôtel, on est assuré d'être bien accueilli, logé, nourri, blanchi.
En même temps, on a souvent une très très grande liberté. Les parents ne poussent plus à prendre son indépendance parce qu'ils acceptent, ils respectent le rythme, l'évolution naturelle des jeunes.
Des expressions qui étaient encore familières quand j'étais adolescent comme voler de ses propres ailes ont quasiment disparu du vocabulaire.
Et les jeunes, non seulement n'ont pas besoin de prendre une indépendance qui était synonyme de liberté puisqu'ils vivent dans des familles où ils sont beaucoup plus libres
qu'auparavant, mais en plus, ils ne sont pas armés de la même manière pour assumer cette indépendance puisque on ne les éduque plus dès le plus jeune âge à
prouver dès leurs dix-huit ou vingt et un ans qu'ils vont pouvoir se prendre en main.
On ne les force plus autant qu'avant à suivre leurs études en respectant le rythme. On n'accompagne plus les devoirs scolaires avec la même autorité, avec la même obligation de se soumettre aux règles et avec
ce qui était classique avant, le redoublement des mauvais points obtenus à l'école par une sanction à la maison.
Aujourd'hui, vous avez généralement ou souvent quand il y a sanction à l'école, un certain nombre de parents qui viennent protester à l'école contre la sanction, qui est un phénomène qu'on ne connaissait pas il y a plus d'un demi-siècle.
Et donc dans cette atmosphère plus ouverte, bienveillante, respectueuse de la sensibilité, des envies, du rythme naturel de croissance des adolescents et des enfants, on peut alors bien voir se développer
une sorte de slow generation qui déciderait de prendre un peu plus son temps pour les études, d'un petit peu plus se consacrer à ses loisirs,
de ne pas faire un drame du fait qu'il faut huit ans plutôt que cinq pour boucler ses études universitaires parce qu'on n'est pas obsédé par l'ancien schéma
de réalisation de soi, de manière ascensionnelle pour montrer qu'on a atteint ou réussi à atteindre une ambition très élevée.
On voit beaucoup plus de jeunes qui tâtonnent parce qu'ils veulent trouver ce qui leur convient
comme études et puis comme travail, qui veulent un travail qui a du sens, un travail respectueux de leurs valeurs, des valeurs humanistes, des valeurs de respect de l'environnement, des valeurs de solidarité.
Donc, ils ne vont pas vouloir entrer très vite, par exemple, dans le circuit adulte du travail, gagner sa vie à tout prix et puis accepter toutes les contraintes de la vie en entreprise.
On va chercher plutôt de concilier le travail et l'épanouissement. Et de la même manière, sur la question de la famille, Twenge observe avec inquiétude que de plus en plus de jeunes, j'ai oublié ça dans mon tableau,
retardent le moment de l'entrée en couple, pas seulement du mariage, mais de la mise en couple.
Donc cette forme d'autonomie et de responsabilité qu'est l'installation en couple. De plus en plus, soit ils restent chez les parents, soit ils vivent seuls et ils ont des relations qui sont moins longues, moins installées sur la durée,
moins responsabilisantes parce que là aussi, on veut d'abord
se donner le temps, on veut pas obéir à une injonction de mariage précoce, de mise en ménage précoce parce que la société attendrait ça.
Et si on veut d'abord satisfaire ses propres désirs, son propre épanouissement, est-on pleinement prêt au compromis, à la patience, aux négociations qu'impliquent la vie à deux, avec la part de prise en compte de la volonté d'autrui ?
Il y a explosion du nombre de divorces, il y a explosion du nombre de séparations. Il y a ce phénomène de plus en plus fréquent
de relations amoureuses où chacun vit de son côté en assumant qu'on a envie de pouvoir mener sa vie chez soi comme on l'entend et on se retrouve avec la personne de son choix au moment voulu.
Et donc ce retard de maturation que Twenge constate de manière très alarmiste, je pense qu'on peut d'abord en adoucir le tableau.
Apparemment, en Europe, c'est un peu plus complexe, mais surtout se dire que c'est une évolution assez naturelle, un prolongement assez naturel de l'individualisme contemporain tel que Yonnet l'analyse.
Alors c'est assez amusant, Twenge est une Américaine bien conforme. À un moment, elle s'inquiète que tout ça soit mauvais pour l'économie américaine.
Ah oui.
Parce que ces jeunes, ils sont prêts, ils sont prêts à faire très vite des études, à les réussir et puis aller travailler et puis à se sacrifier pour l'entreprise.
Les jeunes répondraient : l'économie américaine ou l'économie, ce n'est pas notre préoccupation. Nous avons un souci d'épanouissement, mais aussi un souci de bienveillance pour les autres et pour la planète.
Et c'est ça la nouvelle valeur aujourd'hui ou le nouveau système de valeurs, plutôt que se conformer à une obligation de réussite qui, elle, est héritée vraiment des siècles précédents.
C'est fascinant. Moi, j'ai vingt-six ans et je connais plusieurs personnes qui ont à peu près mon âge
qui n'ont vraiment pas envie qu'on dise qu'ils et elles sont adultes, et qui sont plutôt attachés à une forme de—
Tout à fait. Et on connaît le grand nombre d'entreprises aujourd'hui de petites tailles créées par des vingtenaires, des trentenaires,
qui veulent créer un outil de travail qui fasse sens, qui soit respectueux de leurs valeurs, qui soit respectueux d'une solidarité
avec les pays émergents ou les pays moins développés.
On ne veut plus exploiter, on ne veut plus saccager la planète, on ne veut plus se tuer au travail. On n'a plus le schéma de trouver la meilleure boîte qui va donner le meilleur salaire et qui va permettre de monter en grade.
Ça existe encore, mais c'est moins fréquent. Ce n'est plus le schéma ultra-dominant qu'on a connu.
Vincent de Coorebyter, on arrive au bout de cet entretien. Je rappelle pour celles et ceux que ça intéresse que vous avez publié donc un livre nommé Deux figures de l'individualisme en 2015, à l'Académie Royale de Belgique.
Et vous avez également écrit la préface du livre de Twenge qu'on évoquait tout à l'heure, L'inquiétante étrangeté de la jeune génération, paru en 2018.
Est-ce qu'il y a d'autres choses que vous souhaitez promouvoir, d'autres endroits où on peut vous lire ?
L'inquiétante étrangeté de la jeune génération, c'est le titre de ma préface.
Oui, tout à fait, oui.
Le livre, c'est Génération Internet. Si on veut se le procurer, c'est évidemment ça qu'on doit chercher.
Est-ce qu'il y a d'autres endroits où on peut vous lire, vous consulter ? Est-ce que vous êtes sur les réseaux sociaux ? Est-ce que—
Je ne suis sur aucun réseau social et je ne serai jamais sur un réseau social.
Ah.
C'est ma manière de résister à un certain nombre d'injonctions et de périls de l'individualisme et de ces spirales potentiellement négatives.
Je n'en tire aucune fierté, mais c'est une manière de se protéger.
Vincent de Coorebyter, merci beaucoup.
Merci à vous.
Au revoir. Voilà, j'espère que ça vous a plu. Encore désolé pour la qualité du son. Je vous promets que ça n'arrivera plus.
Si vous avez aimé cet épisode, n'hésitez pas à en parler autour de vous et à le partager sur les réseaux sociaux. Ça m'aide énormément.
Et si ce n'est pas encore fait, n'oubliez pas de vous abonner à Septante Minutes Avec sur votre plateforme de podcast préférée, ainsi que sur Facebook et Twitter.
Dans les mois qui viennent, il y a beaucoup de sujets que j'aimerais aborder. Dans le désordre, il y a par exemple la Russie et en particulier le Kremlin et ses alliés à l'étranger, les troubles de l'alimentation comme l'anorexie, etc.
Peut-être Zakia Khattabi et Caroline Désir, qui sont respectivement ministre fédérale de l'Environnement et ministre de l'Enseignement obligatoire en Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles.
Jean-Marc Jancovici, qui est un écologiste français avec des points de vue assez atypiques, on va dire. Et enfin, on m'a proposé d'interviewer les CEO de Proximus et de Orange.
À voir. Bref, plein d'idées. On verra ce que ça donne. Surtout, si vous avez des suggestions ou des retours, n'hésitez pas à m'en faire part.
Tous les liens et mon adresse e-mail sont dans la description. À très bientôt.